for Walman moving in to Brink [Applause]
it played into the middle but knocked away
chernak gave it away to bring it with a shot but
where they score they bang it home Daniel strong
who scored in the first game scores [Music]
tonight find the buck it was a it might have
been a of a screenshot it's a turnover by Tampa
Bay it was a bit of a screenshot it trickled in
behind him good look at it there and sprung
as I mentioned in our open ever since charlot
toown in the Quebec league has scored goals
wherever he has been and he gets his second
goal of the Season already he had four in four
games in training camp and the first one bounced
off his leg in New Jersey college roommate
back in the day it's loose in front of the
goal big save H rebound I think he got that one
too lightning come back in with it honor Sherry
stops inside the line and looks here for beleno
along with wman it's a 2 on0 Baleno to wman and
a big save there by Johanson a two on0 I thought
they were going to go give it and give it back
and free the goal tender headman for cochero
COK for headman across the shot they score
beautifully set up didn't score earlier but
Stam Co gets that one on the heels of a two
on0 CER off involved again that's
a really great setup by headman for
sure oh as much as coov scores MC you were
talking he's one of the the best passers in
the league headman's not not too bad either
and stos in his wheelhouse if it's not on
a power play from a little further back edman
and coocher off assisting at 946 to tie up the
game all alone again St post denied there and
a big stop and that's a huge stop marked that
one down at the halfway point of the period
be a terrific power play performer for the
Red Wings as he shown thus far here's Raymond
for lin Lin right out oh touch back big save
there by yonas Johansson the goenda it braon
able to knock it down Pon with top find r m
goes back to the line for sherat cross now for
mat mat got the shot fronted there by hman and
a long pass and it's a good one here's Hegel
all alone and he scores Brandon Hegel set up
from long [Music] distance blocked shot by
headman Beau took off from he he had gone to
the point to try to cover Ma and he makes no
mistake two to one Tampa Bay just like that
boy oh boy what a crazy first period this is hman
with three assists already in a game and 13 plus
minutes certainly a long way from being
done but but in his 30s they want to see
and without vast Lefty here's slot there for lin
they want to see where their team is going to be
here's the brink and that shot gets deflected
high on the attempt from Lin the Brink's got
it what did that hit what the heck did that get
in it's a 10 t tie Alex to break it and his Red
Wing home debut has tied up his son Archie and
wife Lindsay expecting again and he's wearing
number 93 for older brother Andrew they uh he
did everything Andrew was doing and uh played
hockey together growing up they're a team that's
still going to be reckoned with and if they can
weather the storm if there is one without
the top goalie in the league being in the
game they're going to be uh be heard from by
the end of the year scores Raymond top shelf
for Raymond and it's three to [Applause] [Music]
[Applause] two it's a four Che of Dylan Lin here
that creates a turnover just too much pressure and
that shot went between the legs of Sherry and the
goal tender I don't think picked it up AR goalie
Aussie herit chased by R lose F there for C got
hit by hetman Corelli ahead Brandon Hegel with a
good feed stamp CO's in there's the shot of scores
whoa that's why stampco scores like he does his
second of the night boy oh boy it's three three
yeah it's not exactly a
it's a partial odd man rush
but he wasn't going to pass all I it's a
perfect shot but Detroit actually got back
ahead for confer wman joining he's got it
he shoots it that hit the leg go of radish
hop to cider in tight scars T in front poer
it's 4 to [Applause] [Music] [Applause] three
nobody at the point to cover cider and there's
the Reach In by Comer and he gets the lucky bounce
that the golender can only hope it hits him and
boy it's been one of those kind of games at both
ends kill for Detroit carried over from the
second period G get a big kill right here
with kucherov and the boys out there
kerov at point but both played over
15 minutes and for forwards that's a lot
well now they called up Zack Aston Reese
with fabri injured [Applause] shortterm
knocked away here's a break Dillan lurin
with the Bret there's SC what a play by
lurin whoa you talk about unselfish oh
man
boy the speed and the strength of of skating
for Dylan Lin showed there and there's again
you spoke about the release of debret earlier in
the game if he doesn't snap this Puck immediately
he doesn't handle it he probably doesn't
score settled it down gives it to cucher
off and across the stamp Co watched by cider but
found headman watched by cop swings It Wide for
ceron headman they'll look stamp Coast his way no
he scores hman with a high wrer that's where they
were going Ken back to 77 almost every play
and that's the the reason that Detroit was
really really really upset showing no emotion at
all screen the front of the net a big wrist shot
from a guy that's 66 that deflected off Lin
I think it goes right into the top corner and
once again we got a and you see the presence of
Nick Paul there luck tough draw cider into help
Lin good job on the face off and cider will
dump it that should do it yes it should wide
edging shots but the score is tight and the
Red Wings win by one their home opener one
one the he scored I think it went in before
before who done it was it Lin I think went
in with one1 second left four win yes 7 six10
to go cider gets the goal wow along with an
assist what a hockey game what a
way to open the season holy MEA